que el plan de infraestructura de 12
billones de dólares está atado a la plan
social de 175 millones de dólares y lo
que hace falta es que los demócratas que
tienen la mayoría tanto en el senado
como en la cámara de representantes se
pongan de acuerdo es decir que los
demócratas moderados se pongan de
acuerdo en el senado para aprobar el
plan social y una vez sea aprobado este
texto se ha afirmado sea públicamente
aprobado por tanto la mayoría demócrata
como también por joe manchin o euros
cinema que son dos senadores que pues
son los que han sido la piedra en el
zapato para terminar de aprobar este
plan social en el senado una vez todos
se pongan de acuerdo esa mayoría se
asegure el senado los demócratas en la
cámara de representantes donde también
son mayoría se comprometen entonces a
votar no solamente el plan de
infraestructura sino también el plan
social y por eso es que yo bailén visitó
esta mañana antes de salir a europa a el
congreso para tratar de llevarse una
noticia positiva
a europa y tratar de que estas
diferencias pues ya fueran terminadas y
se pudiera llevar el plan firmado la
promesa de que se fuera a firmar hoy sin
embargo el plan de infraestructura y el
plan social no han sido todavía
aprobados del todo en el senado y en la
cámara de representantes y nuevamente se
aplaza entonces el voto del plan de
infraestructura y por ende entonces del
plan social bueno y entonces como será
la agenda de bailén en europa
claro y hay que resaltar también que
ballen dijo que tratando de hacerle
publicidad de este plan social que no va
a incrementar el déficit fiscal como lo
argumentan los republicanos ni tampoco
pues va a generar una presión
inflacionaria pero la agenda entonces
completamente viaja viaja viajo salió
hoy de washington entonces llega a roma
el viernes se reúne con el papá el
viernes también el sábado y el domingo
tendrá esta cumbre de los países del g20
donde entre otras cosas se reunirá con
el presidente manuel macro de francia
para hablar sobre este negocio que pues
rompió de alguna manera las relaciones
bilaterales entre francia y estados
unidos y después entonces viajaría a a
escocia glasgow para lunes y martes de
la próxima semana estar en la copa 20 en
esta reunión de países y de líderes que
se van a comprometer para poder hacer un
cambio climático comprometerse con
acciones concretas para mitigar el
cambio climático hay que resaltar que en
la reunión que tendrá el sábado y el
domingo yo baile con los líderes del g20
no estarán presentes en esta reunión de
líderes ni rusia ni china ni mexico es
decir aquí hay un tema que muchos
analistas están diciendo se divide aún
más está este eje de los países
occidentales en eeuu y europa versus
china y rúsia que pues obviamente son y
han sido durante mucho tiempo
contrincantes de eeuu y de occidente